sambusas are everywhere in kenya and
they are an amazing snack
jambo
hi i'm keanu and i'm here with my mom
katana
and today we're gonna make you kenyan
sambusas so typically for my family back
home in kenya we'll make some loses when
we have get-togethers with the family
when i have thanksgiving or christmas
and our whole family runs off of african
people time so waiting for everyone to
ride for christmas or thanksgiving can
be a couple hours so these
literally save lives from anger i am
from the maasai tribe we are livestock
farmers and we love
meat milk all the things from the cows
all things from the cows for maasai
people we don't like to spice our foods
a lot so we like to taste the meat it
smells good i'm getting a meat facial i
don't mind it that meat filling is
on point
so as much as it is like a preparation
of a meal it's a group activity my
favorite part about making sambusas is
really having the ladies sit together
and each person take a piece of uh the
action and get their some bruises done
in a few minutes dough making and
donating is not my favorite part so i
leave this bed to my mom which i don't
mind kneading the dough and it's really
you just have to get right in it and
just do it just do it until it's nice
and soft i mean who needs a gym while
you're making sambusas right correct
it's important to make sure it doesn't
dry out so cover it in cling film and a
warm damp tea towel will help make sure
your sandbooster carries on to that
final very important folding stage
cooking for keanu is passion for me
i'm the oldest of 11 kids so cooking
growing up was work i started fidgeting
in the kitchen with my mom when i was
like around six seven years old the
kitchen for me was always an open place
where i was allowed to be creative and
experiment let me say this she has
overtaken the kitchen since i was once
the chef
and now i'm the sous chef
when you're part cooking your sambucio
dough you just want to get rid of that
stickiness you don't want to fully cook
it into bread you just want it to be a
bit more malleable so to make your
individual wrappers fold it into a
little ice cream cone shape you have a
little flower paste and use a lot of it
probably more than you think you need
you want to lock it in there fry baby
fry mom this is all you
i need to not burn my eyebrows off i
love frying this is the easy part
they're done they didn't fall apart
that's always a good sign i'm so excited
to eat those
i love mine with a lot of lime juice on
it all right cheers mama cheers
this is great
cheers well done ma thank you well then
sweetie oh yes
[Music]
oh